Жорстка протидія біженцям – такий шлях обрала Угорщина.
Прем’р-міністр Віктор Орбан прагне відвадити мігрантів від своєї країни
та провокує Захід,
під час виборчої кампанії.
. Загроза, з якою ми зіткнулися, походить із Заходу,
від політиків із Брюсселя, Берліна чи Парижа.
они хочуть перетворити нашу державу на країну іммігрантів
і таким чином дати початок занепаду християнства
та водночас - прийняття ісламу.
За словами Орбана, тільки одна людина
винна в тому, що Європу заполонили біженці.
І ця людина - Джордж Сорос. Мільярдер, банкір,
уроджений угорець, критик уряду.
І офіційний Будапешт не пошкодував мільйонів
на рекламну кампанію проти Сороса.
Мовляв, саме Сорос послав сотні тисяч біженців у Європу
заради власних політичних інтересів.
Про інших критиків уряду також не забули.
Уряд намагається взяти під контроль інші громадські організації,
такі як Гельсінська спілка з прав людини.
У відповідь на ту роботу, яку ми проводимо,
нас називають небажаною організацією.
А також такою, що загрожує національній безпеці.
Я не буду заперечувати, що ми зіткнулися
із загрозою існуванню нашої організації.
Правозахистні організації - не єдині, які почуваються в небезпеці.
Війна проти Сороса стала і війною проти тих,
з ким він пов'язаний.
Оскільки Сорос - єврей, який пережив концтабір,
єврейська громада в Будапешті
дуже стурбована хвилею пропаганди проти нього.
Це наче вогонь, що поволі розповзається.
Уряд сіє страх - як вогонь - поміж людей,
і ми вже спостерігаємо наслідки.
Підбурюються емоції, що можуть посилити антисемітизм.
Останні соціологічні опитування показують,
що партія прем'єра-популіста Орбана - "Фідес" -
лідирує за симпатіями виборців.
Їй обіцяють 30% голосів.
На другому місці правопопулістська партія "Йоббік",
її підтримують 12-14% угорців.
Лідери "Йоббіка" вже оголосили, що готові уввійти
до майбутнього уряду Орбана.
Тоді праві настрої в угорській владі стануть ще сильнішими.